[Music]
let's go out to Washington DC and talk
to Lee what's up
Lee hi Dr John how are you we doing
great how about
you I'm doing great thank you for taking
my call you got it what's
up okay so about a week and a half ago
my really good longtime friend lost her
sibling uh tragically in a car accident
and they were really close yeah um also
in recent years another immediate family
member of hers uh one of her parents um
unexpectedly passed away so our family
has kind of been drugged through like
all the levels of hell that no one
should have to go through just in the
past couple of years so last week was
the siblings visitation and funeral at
the funeral I saw a lot of old friends
we spent a lot of our 20s with you know
doing the usual 20s something thing
and so we gathered in a group in the
back of the visitation room and
proceeded to talk laugh and carry on
about times in our 20s you know people's
new kids divorces work all the topics
that you would catch up on with someone
like more at a bar or out to lunch and I
didn't realize until probably 10 minutes
in that we were all receiving stairs
from people in the room it was kind of
like we had totally forgotten where we
were and that there wasn't an open
casket in the front of the room and our
friend and her family weren't heavily
grieving um Lee you're the worst you're
the worst friend ever I'm totally
kidding totally kidding well you know a
child lost its parent and we were kind
of carrying on really loudly um
obviously not on purpose but that night
I woke up in the middle of the night
just feeling super sick to my stomach
that I may have actually really hurt my
friend and her
family um my friend's like the most
genuine and kind person I've ever met in
my life in 15 years she's never said a
bad word about anybody have you called
her um well that's my
question um so the next day at the
funeral no one mentioned anything about
it uh but of course my question for you
is is do I go and apologize to her do I
even say
anything um I think it I I've been you
I've done that exactly what you're
talking about
and for me it's twofold number one
that's how I handle grief as I laugh or
I handle that discomfort
okay um and it's probably just hanging
out with First Responders too long but
it it's a it's a very blue dark black
sense of
humor the second thing is um is I have a
picture in my head and I have forever of
my funeral I want everybody laughing
their heads off I even wrote out what I
want to happen at my funeral with a
couple of friends having to sing certain
karaoke songs just so everyone would
laugh my wife said I'm not doing any of
that stuff I'm not doing chores for you
and you're dead but but like I I that's
my picture and I
also have realized over time that's not
everybody else's picture right and so
I've been you what I would do in your
situation is are you all in the same
town yes okay I would just say hey kind
of take you to
coffee and it's not about absolving
yourself you don't want her and her
grief to have to take care of you right
now but I do think it's a good moment to
check in on
her um usually after the funeral after
someone loses especially a child or a
sibling a close sibling it's that 30
days sometimes I'll put a star on my
calendar a week out and then 30 days out
and then maybe again six months out
because that's when things get real real
quiet and you reaching out a week after
two weeks after and saying hey can we go
get coffee and you just using that time
how are you and if it comes up
naturally say hey we saw a bunch of old
friends we were being so obnoxious and
I'm so
sorry and that will give her an
opportunity to say yeah I heard that
you're the
worst or she'll say I I was so in my
black hole that I didn't even realize it
I'm glad y'all got to catch
up
which is I think about 95% of people
would say the
latter okay and I'm glad you mentioned
you know reaching out and that was kind
of my next question is um you know we
had plans to go and do these really fun
things um you know for fall and for
winter do I still invite her out to do
okay absolutely
yes my mom said that she's never going
to be the same after this so I'm kind of
she's an adult she get she gets to she's
an adult and she gets to decide what she
does
next okay what we don't want to do is
create artificially create lone
loneliness in her
life as she's struggling for the words
to say the things that she even needs
what she
wants um we don't want to just quote
unquote give her space and all a sudden
her whole network shuts off thinking
they're helping out
I would give her an opportunity to say
I'm not ready for that right
now okay and you need to just know every
time you reach out and say hey um I
think it all starts with a cup of coffee
or just go grab a drink and just hang
out
um but I think every time you invite her
on that weekend trip every time you
invite her that Airbnb every time you
invite her to that concert if she says
no just know that has nothing to do with
you she's just grieving and struggling
and some some days in her grief um will
be up days and some days she's not going
to want to get out from from under the
coverage and that's cool and maybe you
skip the weekend retreat and say hey if
I brought over a bunch of cheeseburgers
and some nachos you just want to watch
Ted lasso reruns and she might be like
yes and she might say I just need some
time about
myself okay is that you see what I'm
saying yeah that makes sense and I'll
tell you I mean I tell everybody this
but so
often we we have no
um we have no road map for sitting with
people who are hurting because of loss
or because of cancer because of
whatever that we all end up leaning on
the hurting person to make us feel
better because we don't know what to do
with our
discomfort and I would tell you just to
be real cognizant of not using
her and her going out with you her and
her saying it's okay that you all were
causing a scene in the back of the room
like it's not her job to prop you all up
right now it's vice versa it's her
friend's job to come hold her arms up in
the desert because she can't breathe see
the
difference I do and that's why I asked
the question because again in my mind
it's like I I hope I didn't cause her
any more pain than what she's already
going through you probably
didn't you probably
didn't okay you probably didn't I'd be
willing to bet you didn't
you might have bothered her aunt so and
so or whatever um but she doesn't get a
vote and maybe you did maybe she's going
to be really upset with you and if she
is so be it I mean at that point what do
you say you say like I'm really
sorry right like I didn't have like I
got uncomfortable and I saw some old
friends and it was easy to distract
myself I just didn't handle it right I'm
sorry I mean what else you going to say
right well that's the truth yeah was
super uncool and I'm
sorry okay if it were my
friends and I lost one of my
siblings and a bunch of my friends
showed up and they were in the back
laughing I would be grateful for
that so everybody's going to respond
differently I think the thing to not do
is avoid your friend I think is to head
directly into that discomfort and just
put all out on the table but only after
you spent some time saying hey how are
you
the week after the funeral the month
after the funeral the six months after
the funeral after all of the emails and
cards stop and all of the condolences
stop and the bills get paid and the
insurance stuff comes through after all
that it gets really really
quiet real
quiet and that's when the real friends
show up not the hangers on in the high
fivers and the peripheral friends who
legitimately feel bad that you lost a
child or that you're sick or that you
know that your sibling passed away
they're really sad but they move on your
Rider dies those you're really close to
it affects yall y'all's life is
different now
too and so like I say I will put a star
in my calendar for a week out sometimes
a month out sometimes six months out and
just make sure I reach out because
things get real
quiet so reach out tell you want take
her to coffee and if she says I don't
want to go with you I don't want to go
with you and you reach out in another
week I don't want to go with you reach
out in another week I don't want to go
with you then you could say hey are you
are we cool are we cool and then maybe
she'll say no you're a jerk you were
laughing at my at my siblings funeral
and you can say I'm sorry I didn't
handle that right I was weirded out and
I was uncool I saw some old friends I
was
uncool and then she gets to heal on her
own but I don't think that's going to be
the case she's lucky to have you Lee
she's lucky to have you Reach
Out